wir haben sie geöffnet und dann sahen
wir das hakenkreuz
ich konnte es nicht glauben und wir
waren erstmal still
natürlich waren wir sauer und wollten
unsere nachbarn wissen lassen was dort
passiert ist damit sie nicht mehr
dorthin gehen deswegen haben wir es auf
social media gepostet am sonntagmorgen
haben wir bemerkt dass es viral geht
[Musik]
leute von überall her haben kommentiert
auch hass kommentare aber besonders in
zeiten von rassismus und sexismus können
diese themen verletzten
auch wenn sie nur lustig gemeint sind
sie haben sich sofort dafür entschuldigt
und gesagt es war keine absicht sie
erklärten die situation als einen prank
an einem anderen mitarbeiter und der
wusste nicht was drin ist als er sie mir
gegeben hat in dieser nacht waren wir
sehr besorgt was sonst noch mit unserer
pizza passieren könnte vielleicht haben
sie uns ja darauf gespuckt natürlich
haben wir sie nicht vergessen aber sie
nur zusehen wird uns schon erschossen